نهبوا مستشفيات وتدميرها احتجاز اطباء
ومنعهم من علاج المرضى لائحه اتهام طويله
سقطها منظمه الصحه العالميه لروسيا فالدب
روسي نفث غضبه خلال اشهر من الحرب
باتجاهات اوكرانيه عده بينها القطاع الصحي
منظمه الصحه العالميه رصدت الف هجوم
الروسي ضد المستشفيات والمراكز الصحيه
والاطباق في اوكرانيا منذ بدء العمليه
العسكريه واسفلت تلك الهجمات عن مقتل نحو
100 شخص بينهم عاملون في الحقل الطبي
ومرضى وفق صحيفه تيليجراف البريطانيه
الصحه العالميه وصفت هذه الهجمات بجريمه
حرب وانتهاك القانون الانساني الدولي
مصنفه هذا العدد بالاعلى على الاطلاق في
ظل الاعلان عن حاله طوارئ انسانيه اما اهم
مناطق توزع هذه الاعتداءات فهي خرسون
حيث حضرت منظمه الصحه العالميه من زياده
الوفيات وتدهور النظام الصحي على الماده
الطويل اذا تواصلت الهجمات ضد المنشات
الطبيه لسيما تاثير الهجمات النفس على
المرضى سوف يجعلهم يخشون فكره طلب
المساعده لسنوات
لمتابعه المزيد من الاخبار والبرامج
والقصص الانسانيه والوثائقيات والتقارير
الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في قناتنا
على اليوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل
جرس التنبيهات